du bist nervös wie so einfach sein
gegner stark machen der tag soll es soll
das projekt das ich denke ja die kräfte
sondern es gab damit bis gott da ich nie
einig wie sie musikalisch historische
läuft ja sie um es kurz zu machen von
der fähigkeit des menschen vor freude zu
empfinden sich selber zu freuen und die
freude anderen menschen weiterzugeben
also von lauter freude und von nichts
anderem handelt dieser film telefonen
verliert michael von der heides freude
kommt nicht von ungefähr
sein idol paola felix höchstselbst hat
sich angekündigt und bringt ihm
wertvolle original aufnahmen ihrer
lieder aus den 70er jahren mit weichen
abgestempelt 18 oktober 1972 mit der
idee auf sie zurück wenn er vor dem
projekt mit mir geredet kann ich habe
nachgerechnet was ist der grund ist es
irgend der jahreszahl aber gesagt ja ich
möchte das bühnenprogramm machen mit den
alliierten das finde ich wunderbar als
und das aber nur zehn mache ich mich
sehr gefreut
dass du wohl weiß ich das so schöne
archiviert das jetzt einfach eine dufte
lösch knopfdruck so jetzt ja
[Musik]
wie ist
menschen
so probierte ich befragt dhz kann ebenso
oder x 2 gespielt so schön
[Musik]
o
das scheint die liebe uns vereint und in
andere hinein wenn man sehen dass nur
das ist nichts gespielt hat sie bereit
wenn du ihren hilft nicht wenn du
fotobuch spende jetzt dem fall das
playback bruch schwenkt du irgendwelche
informationen bedienen rezepte aber
sonst muss ich sagen ich mich überrascht
das publikum
[Musik]
zwei jahre lang trug michael von der
heide
die idee mit sich herum sein großes
vorbild mit einer hommage zu ehren
zwei jahre in denen er songs für eine cd
und für das bühnenprogramm bestimmen
musste
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein sie sich hat die qual der wahl oder
meine sind übergab sie die 150 songs und
natürlich cinéma wie es erweckt das ist
ja doch nichts erstmals sehe oder warnow
und wollte ich nicht quasi sie verliebt
dann sind die musik verliebt haben und
die eurovision song contest also das
muss ich machen das ganz kraft es sind
lieder die eine friedliche welt zum
inhalt haben eine neue sicht auf die
dinge könnte man sagen michael von der
heide und mit ihm hunderttausende
fühlten sich von carola auf anhieb
angesprochen
[Musik]
wie sind sie bemühen xii
ich will hier raus ich bin doch wo ist
dein kreis hat sie hier auch die disc
sich also irgendwie wieder nach hinten
[Gelächter]
träumen ist das so die frau meiner
träume sie und er hat sich da ich habe
die bilder von mir ich weiß dass ich im
sonntagsblick sie muss ich so glücklich
ist und der kurzfrist wo sie so
glücklich sind dann ich mich hat gefreut
und die bildrate und ich weiß sein oder
sie als blut stoß wirklichkeit und das
steht heute so populär akz i und ii
werden das obligate derzeit so wirken
das ist wie üblich zieht das ist auch
extravagante bluetooth liegt mir die
meister nicht rosen oder so aber laut
paola aber speziell xi elegant also oder
bewusst also um format zu machen jahr
später ich sage oft wie nie den namen
die ich habe immer gesagt ich hier auch
die frau und das paola und wenn ich sie
nicht gerade ein halt mögen das beliebte
die also der aufgang aber zugute kommt
macht sehr erfreut
[Musik]
wo ist das land dafür eine miete erstes
land will sie ein haus nach 21 jahren
[Musik]
wo ist das ist das land wo es nur die
liebe gibt wo man nur den frieden liegt
dort wo allen
die
da muss ich mich einfach will das gesetz
ist paula sind das so muss ich probiere
mich um 4 oder muss nicht arm und es
würde dann doch die ein ziele oder sie
haben das ist wie immer der richtige ton
oder laichingen ich probiere so dass ich
nach 1 44 jahre liegen zwischen der
aufnahme von paola und jene von der
heides die gefahr dass das land
inzwischen gefunden worden wäre ist
gering
[Musik]
dort wo alle
menschen sich verstehen
[Musik]
er ist das land wo es nur die liebe gibt
wo man nur den frieden liegt dort wo
alle menschen sich verstehen
dani wilde tiere
[Musik]
ja die welt war noch einigermaßen heil
als michael von der heide in amden hoch
über dem walensee aufwuchs er habe
krankenschwester gelernt sagt er
geld rein dem irgend kann hier und da
sah er gehänselt worden aber so richtig
schlimm sei es nie gewesen
seine eltern leben immer noch hier
der sohn besucht sie so oft wie seine
eltern eben besuchen nämlich in deren
augen viel zu selten
hallo hier also hatte sich die familie
von der heide in der stube gemeinsam den
eurovision de la chanson angeschaut
mit einem schlag war michael klar
geworden wo sein platz in der welt der
einst sein könnte carola hatte klein
michael mit ihrem cinema besucht und war
gleich für immer geblieben
stolz im beruf eigentlich obwohl es
sicher er macht sie wurde wenn er
angelegt sagen macht's gut dass ich
fühle mich ja nicht weg sie das
musikzelt und das ganze ab zügeln und
naja wahrscheinlich freuen tue ich es
sowieso ganze des films muss ich sagen
sie ich hätte allerdings weder machen
und daher dass der nicht überholt ein
hotel für für cd welle machen und er
hätte wenn ihr klebt das team kennt wo
das nächste demo ist um ihr geld das ist
heute noch entweder innovation autor
hätte bisher eine so passion und systeme
wie stolz die eltern wirklich sind zeigt
der blick in schachteln voller halb
vergilbter erinnerung habe schon alles
gemacht hat was ich wirklich kann eine
spende für paolo versteht sich so gar
nicht mag locken
ja er müsste nur viel mehr wenn die
wüssten dass er in diesen tagen an
keinem ort so oft ist wie in ampen zu
besuch in der eigenen kindheit noch viel
von ihm hören
[Musik]
apa
in seinem leben
ganz wichtig
erwachsenwerden hat ihn mit sternenstaub
bestellt und dann wie ein kind konnte
wie ein vogel fliegt
auf jeden fall plektrum
auf der probebühne arbeitet von der
heide mit regisseurin und musiker ein
programm das in wenigen tagen premiere
feiert die mache dass er die zähne zu es
geht denn so sachen lkws wieder gemerkt
jetzt ist und macht das politische zu
oder wichtige element wie das in das
zimmer mit der banane segen vom spiegel
das muss ihnen aber wenn man dann den
dass händler oder führe also das machen
seine machen
die grundidee von schon vor ihm so also
vor ganze und ich bin einfach dazu
okay was funktioniert aber es hat mir
noch mal für die zwischen einer vorrang
was musikalisch
und schon bald 1
superstar
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
applaus applaus applaus applaus schon
begrifflich und begrüßen andere cruz
stimmen also hallo kreis kosten hatte
und die in unterwäsche im budget eine
abzocke armen hast du jetzt da sowohl
die funktion von bischofsheim
es war zwar und schuhe aber erste silly
und zur weißglut sich zu europa michael
von der heide kann auf ein ihm
vertrautes ensemble zählen die kostüme
für die show hat der modedesigner willy
spiels kreiert der seit 22 jahren sein
lebenspartner ist jetzt im kostüm der
chef wer entscheidet und sicherheit
das ist es womit er sein es das passt
nicht das ist viel geld mache nicht
absitzen den gott seien nicht also genau
dies wird im regen haben wir jetzt noch
nicht im traum
es stimmt es ist wichtig sie wie sie
ihre faktische schneedruck sie sie liebt
mode sich immer alamode und sind es auch
die element und sagt wo man hat also
inspiration und weniger verzaubert der
eleganz und das probieren bereich oder
ich meine aber dass kein mitspracherecht
was musik gegangen ich habe ihn sprach
recht windig so ich bin artikel group
ihr alles sind im video das er ist der
erste der leitstelle wie sie es einmal
einmal mit ein aber ich habe mal wieder
los
[Musik]
bonjour bonjour
es ist schön dich mal wieder zu sehen
bonjour bonjour gerade heute seien die
sonne so schön an deiner hand durch die
stadt gehen das wünsche ich mir nur ja
ich finde jetzt auch die brav lustig
muss ich noch nie gesehen oder und
siegel nur den verliebten
die welt ist da die deka nicht schöner
sein
afriso oder konnte mit
die welt ist wunderbar sie kann nicht
schöner sein und siegel verliehen
ein
[Musik]
ist ok weil ich von anfang an spielen
wird ba spielt demnach das ist jetzt
wirklich mein erster und erster zugang
zur rein musikalisch ich meine musik
gehört eigentlich zur tagen im all ist
eine viel weniger oder sogar einzigen
sich der rat musik widmen tut und ich
finde das total lässig hits all die sich
aktiv für ihre stadt von meeres kann
hier das licht aus wenn jetzt die jetzt
vom
[Musik]
sie kann
und dann ist er da der große tag
zusammen mit willi spiels kommt bald zur
premiere das publikum am schluss im
besten fall vor dem auto eine zeitreise
qualifikation
er hoffe der pd so erfrischt präsident
ich sage der wunsch vom künstler freut
es machen irgendwie natürlich also vor
allem also einer der richter es dagegen
es gibt wieder sagen laut der gegend
zwischen powerline hinfällig sein
und es geht noch einmal wichtigsten
weniger gemerkt assistenz erst sieht man
da also weiß ich es probieren also da im
vollbild carola schon g und verglich das
macht und erst einem schuss hätte halt
wissen wo sich nicht nur selbst schluss
dass schon im pokalspiel
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie ein stern der erwartung ein märchen
folkmusik
sie ist auch toll
nur ein kind aus der groß und zehn mal
mein gesicht ist die ganz kleinen
[Musik]
denn noch nie
freiheit
und
sowas
seit ich hier bin
die schon
wie du selbst bleiben eines dicht
[Musik]
nein
so
ein
ich war noch einmal an
irgendwann
dubai
[Musik]
dass die fed bei dir einfach hinter mir
bei
bei dir lernte ich jeden tag wie ein
geschenk zu singen um nichts anderes als
um die freude die es in diesem film
versprachen wir zu beginn
na dann los war
es war schön dich mal wieder zu sehen
[Applaus]